hello i am Francisco Sanchez the u.s.
Under Secretary of Commerce for
international trade and I want to
respond to a question that was presented
by joaquin on unity and throat
to paraphrase a question what can be
done to bring the americas poster
together for mutual prosperity what came
is a very good question and i would say
i would broaden the sphere to what can
the Western Hemisphere do from Canada
all the way down to Argentina and Chile
to work together and I think there is
much that we can do
continue the lower barriers or trade and
investment so that we can sell into each
other's markets so that we can share
technology that can benefit our citizens
and finally there by doing that we
become more competitive piece of the
other parts of the world I believe it's
no longer a luxury or just an
interesting idea to be regionally
integrated I think it's essential in the
competitive world in which we lay so I
would look for ways to more business
together throughout the Western
Hemisphere look for opportunities to
produce products jointly in Brazil umbra
air makes planes that it sells to the
United States and other parts of the
world a large portion of that airplane
is made with us content so while it's an
export from Brazil to the United States
it also benefits companies in the United
States which in turn create jobs in our
own kind of way so looking for ways to
work together like that will be
for us to move forward as a region thank
you